[Applaudissements]
la retraite en france un système unique
par répartition fondé sur la solidarité
inter-générationnelle un système auquel
les français sont très fortement
attachés et qui date est bien de pétain
la retraite des vieux en traction 1941
la france est occupée les personnes
âgées vivent dans une extrême misère
pour éviter la famine le régime de vichy
décide de le redistribuer l'argent des
caisses des cotisations des travailleurs
la retraite des vieux travailleurs
repose sur la solidarité de la nation
solidarité des classes solidarité des
âges puisque ce sont les jeunes
générations qui cotisent pour les
vieilles voilà donc une grande réforme
sociale
c'est donc le régime de vichy qui a posé
les bases de ce que le maréchal pétain
appelle la grande réforme sociale
autrement dit la retraite basé sur la
solidarité inter générationnelle
à la libération les communistes au sein
du gouvernement provisoire reprennent et
défendre ce système les actualités
françaises en faisait même la promotion
la france redevienne un peuple de jeunes
que le travail de tous participent au
repos de ceux qui ont fini de travailler
parmi les promoteurs de cette réforme un
communiste ministre du travail
ambroise croizat voici rassemblés autour
de son chef ce ministère qui apporte
quelque chose de nouveau
c'est ainsi que monsieur ambroise
croizat nouveau ministre du travail est
un métallurgiste encore tout proche
les problèmes qu'il aura à résoudre cet
ancien métallurgiste syndiqués à la cgt
va oeuvrer pour pérenniser et rendre
accessible à tous les français ce
système par répartition pour ça il va
créer une institution la sécurité
sociale qui comportera une branche
vieillesse la retraite par répartition
basé sur la solidarité
intergénérationnelle est désormais
inscrite dans la loi
l'allocation aux vieux sera l'expression
et la teinte de la solidarité de toute
la population française à l'égard des
vieux comment financer cette réforme les
politiques compter sur l'explosion
démographique au lendemain de la guerre
et ça a fonctionné pendant 50 ans ah oui
ah oui ça oui celui me mais dès les
années 90 pierre laroque cofondateur de
la sécurité sociale alertés sur la
pérennité du système
leurs tirs 2005 ou 2010 avec en gros en
moyenne 1,5 actif pour un retraité
et il est évidemment à craindre que l'on
est un jour ou l'autre une révolte des
jeunes contre les vieux
la révolte a bien lieu dans la rue et
sur les réseaux sociaux mais c'est celle
des défenseurs du système par
répartition qui craignent sa disparition
[Musique]